bei mir ist es so gelaufen ich war am
anfang ja natürlich wie alle wie die
meisten komplettes angeknipst von dem
was man sah die bilder die die meldung
von überall her keiner wusste was los
ist ich war dafür sofort die kinder nach
hause zu schicken die schulen zu bis man
weiß was ist denn dann habe ich mich
immer weiter eingelesen werden riesen
fan boy von bostons podcast und so hin
dass immer weiter und und dann kam der
der erste doktor nannten kam so viele
dinge die sich mir überhaupt nicht mehr
erschlossen haben und dann kam die
medien und das war ja so ein bisschen
meiner general kleine attacke mir ist
total klar dass es ungerecht ist mir
total klar dass das undifferenzierte ist
und dass das auch falsch zu verstehen
dass das kann man nicht verhindern das
liegt aber an der kurzen form und an
dieser ironischen und satirischen form
die man einfach wird das ist denn so
kann man nicht differenzieren und auch
noch an alle gleichermaßen länger ist es
jetzt so passiert wie es ist und mir
ging es ich hätte dann einfach irgendein
diesen overkill und ich habe gesagt ich
kann das nicht mehr ich glauben 80 mehr
geschlafen das erste was ich morgens
servern kroner zahlen das letzte was man
abends war die korona nachrichten mich
hat das einfach verfolgten ich wurde
immer carroll am kopf und habe dann
irgendwann gesagt stopp ich habe alle
zeitungen abgestellt ich habe keinen
alle newsfeeds abgestellt ich habe
nichts mehr gesehen keine nachrichten
mehr geguckt und habe mich angefangen um
etwas zu kümmern was für mich mehr sinn
macht ich habe zum beispiel doktor lisa
federle kennengelernt die mir erzählte
von ihren test strategien was alte
menschen ist war die erste frau
überhaupt die alters einmal gegangen ist
und die alten menschen getestet habe von
denen man ja die ganze zeit schon wusste
dass ich ganz besonders variabel sondern
weil es irgendwie nicht macht also sie
fing damit an das hat mich interessiert
dann bin ich da immer weiter angestiegen
dann kam das tübinger modell das ich
sehr unterstützt ab und und bis hin zu
dem appell dann kurz vor dem schließen
und das ja auch funktioniert hat das
wurde ja nicht geschlossen weil das
nicht funktioniert sondern es wurde
geschlossen weil einfach jetzt die große
notbremse kam und so geht das immer
weiter ich will das auch hinkriegen und
bin dann anfang januar habe ich dann
auch wieder angefangen natürlich wieder
die nachrichten zu gucken man kann ja
gar nicht dran vorbei
man muss es ja wahrnehmen weil natürlich
alle um einen herum es auch wahrnehmen
also inzwischen interessanter punkt sie
haben das in der zeit auch erzählt sie
haben es jetzt hier nochmal erzählen
dass sie der fülle der nachrichten und
der berichterstattung überdrüssig war
aber damit muss man ja noch nicht sagen
dass die im ton gleich ist oder den
gleichen einen gleichen chor hat also
sie sagen ja in ihrem stück auch sie
möchten die von gleichschaltung sprechen
aber sie sagen dass die journalisten
eben nicht mehr kritisch waren das ist
ein system von angst gehabt dass nichts
mehr hinterfragt wurde dass der zweifel
bestraft wurde also damit treuen sie
natürlich in diese richtung von wieso
man das sagen
demokratie zweiflern oder verzweiflung
ist ihnen das bewusst dass dieser sound
in ihrem stück man kann es ja nicht
ändern also wenn ich sage 2 + 2 4 dann
dann ist das war richtig aber ich sage
es vielleicht nicht weil ein half dem
mann möglicherweise zu derselben aussage
kenne also wir können auch nicht das was
wir sagen und wie wir darüber sprechen
definieren lassen von denen mit dem wir
nichts zu tun haben wollen also das ist
für mich das leuchtet mir nicht ein
und ich stehe ja nicht für ein system
nämlich für ein system dort sondern ich
stehe für die offene gesellschaft und
für die freiheit der rede und die
freiheit der presse zum beispiel also
dass wir ja mal sagen das ist mir
wirklich nicht egal und ich habe dafür
schon wirklich leute verärgert weil ich
unbedingt eine laudatio halten wollte
bei reporter ohne grenzen für die
freiheit der presse - die sogar so
wichtig dass ich sie verteidigen würde
wenn sie sich gegen mich richtet aber
ich wünsche mir natürlich auch ich
träume davon dass die dass das ein
journalist oder die die presse dann die
freiheit der kunst und der rede auch so
wichtig ist dass sie immer noch
verteidigen würden auch wenn sie sich
mal gegen sie richtet und das ist so
mein mann mein verständnis von meiner
wahrnehmung keine zeitung keine
nachrichtensendung kein magazin auch wir
nicht ich will jetzt gar nicht groß
sagen wenn wir alles in dieser sendung
schon hatten kritiker ausgespart hätte
dies in der politik gab aber auch in der
wissenschaft bei den unternehmern längst
auch bei den künstlern und auch bei
ja irgendwie großen darstellern und
schauspielern also von paul van dyk kati
witt kredite also sebastian pufpaff
hatten wir auch die kunst und künstler
ist natürlich längstens hier in der
sendung will sagen natürlich kritisieren
sie einen journalismus der überall die
regierung kritisiert und auch das was in
dieser ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
nicht durchgängig und auch nicht überall
und ich würde schon sagen ich trete ich
fange gleich beschreibt das was ich
glaube es übrigens auch nicht glaube
nicht dass irgendjemand das
gleichgeschaltet aber ich finde schon
dass das so eine gewisse homogenität in
der berichterstattung dann irgendwann
gab und vor allen dingen das was mich so
angegriffen hat weil dieser alarm und
ich würde mir dann irgendwann auch
wünschen dass es gibt ja nicht nur
unheimlich residente menschen in der
gesellschaft die sagen dass wir jetzt
durch da ist es in ordnung dass es gibt
auch menschen die sind sensibel es gibt
auch übrigens menschen die noch andere
krankheiten haben und es gibt menschen
die brauchen die sozialen kontakte es
gibt kinder gerade wenn es wenn wir in
die prekären bereich des lebens gucken
was familien zerrüttete familien angeht
also dort passiert richtig viel unglück
passiert richtig viel dabei es geht um
gewalt und all diese dinge aber nein es
war sozusagen ein ganz klarer fokus auf
diese eine sache und das fand ich so
viel und ich fand so viel dass dafür
dass so viele menschen in diesem land
die ganze zeit kerngesund verein sag ich
mal oder wenigstens negativer tests
vorzuweisen hatten und dennoch und so
viel solidarität aufgebracht haben die
ganze zeit dafür fand ich dann ist dann
irgendwann auch mal die zeit gekommen
ihnen auch mal was zurückzugeben und es
gab diese möglichkeiten
es gab diese test strategien die man in
tübingen probiert hat oder in rostock
und auch im saarland und das wird dann
alles weggewischt mit dem satz der so
apodiktisch klingt dieses argument es
muss sein
wir sind davon überzeugt es gibt keine
zwei meinungen das ist alternativlos
das ist natürlich ein bisschen schwach
das argument mit der alternativlosigkeit
besonders wenn man um sich herum so
viele alternativen sehen kann
es war wahnsinnig hart erkämpft
streckenweise darüber diskutieren wir
jetzt noch fragen wollte ich sie
vorneweg bevor wir die in die debatte
gehen
neben verstehen warum eine reihe ihrer
kollegen sich im nachhinein entschuldigt
haben für die akte füllten die sich
benutzt mai ganz salopp gefragt dass das
müssen sie selbst fragen das weiß ich
also ich würde ich sehe ich sehe das
auch also wenn es jemanden gäbe dass ich
jetzt von meinem video wirklich
persönlich verletzt fühlen würde und
keine weitergehenden interessen hat ich
gehöre einer bubble an ich möchte dich
vernichten oder ich bin dann würde ich
das sofort tun ich hab überhaupt kein
problem ich damit zu entschuldigen wenn
ich jemandem zu nahe getreten bin nicht
ich würde aber trotzdem diese frage
nicht beantworten können für andere und
wenn sie sich fragen wissen sie welche
rolle die dietrich brüggemann gespielt
hat und welche rolle bern kein wunder
gespielt hat dir als initiatoren gelten
der eine sprach von lynchmob der andere
von coronel also sie kennen die beiden
ich kenne den nein ich kenne nur einen
burger madrid und auch nicht sehr gut
das ist ein kenner als regisseur aber
ist auch musiker und im film brachte mir
super gut gefallen hat und das habe ich
immer geschrieben das war eigentlich
unser ganzer kontakt dann hat er kontakt
zu mir aufgenommen mich gefragt wie es
mir geht mit dem aldi ob ich mich ob ich
mir vorstellen könnte mich an so was zu
beteiligen und das konnte und das war
genug zeit sich das auch zu überlegen
oder war das eine schnelle aktion also
ich bei mir haben sich so viele leute
gemeldet zum beispiel kampagnenmanager
die gesamte kann man das nicht machen
was machen ganz anders aufziehen coaches
die gesagt hat wenn sie in die torchance
erinnern da brauchen sie ein coaching
das geht nicht so also ist es ein
solcher bus um dieses ganze sache
entstanden dass ich mir nicht mehr
sicher bin was die frage war sagt wollte
im grunde nur noch ein bisschen ob sie
zeit hatten darüber nachzudenken bei der
aktion messung nach ja natürlich also
zeit darüber nachzudenken hatte ich
schon aber was ich nicht gemacht habe
ist eine saubere recherche wer ist jetzt
jeder einzelne was ist die vergangenheit
mit wem haben die schüler ja das habe
ich nicht gemacht und das ist auch ein
bisschen so unsere computers komischer
berufsstand weil wir dann einfach ich
kenne einfach sechs sieben leute die
mitmachen
das sind alles ich sag mal kumpels
wirklich freundschaftlich verbunden er
heute
und damit ist die sache für mich denn
eigentlich erst mal
und das habe ich jetzt gelernt das darf
man nämlich machen man muss alles zurück
verfolgen also bis zu den wurzeln der
hat eine webseite angemeldet mit dem
normalen urlaub und so dass und hat
alles schon wieder zugeschneit ist doch
so ein bisschen könnte man sagen einer
der vorwürfe den er sich anhören muss
mit ihnen tim ist bei uns
wissenschaftsjournalistin berühmt und
sowieso berühmt mit miley mieterin
studierte von ihren kindern können sie
uns helfen was auch auf der seite der
kritiker eigentlich los ist da werden
eben listen angefertigt er wird mit
berufsverboten gedroht da wird
verleugnet also menschen die eigentlich
sich rationalität zu gute halten warum
zählen die so aus in reaktion auf die
alters das kann das kann ich nicht
beantworten das kann man vielleicht
jetzt wissenschaftlich psychologisch
analysieren aber diese extrem meinung
gibt es natürlich immer das sind sehr
wenige leute die natürlich dann in
unserer aktuellen medienlandschaft sehr
viel gehör bekommen und ich muss auch
zugeben ich habe die aktion als dicht
machten gar nicht so stark verfolgt also
deswegen auch schon mal als disclaimer
vorweg ich habe mich alle videos gesehen
ich habe auch tatsächlich diskussion im
nachgang nicht im detail verfolgt uns
war bewusst weil ich nicht denke dass
jede diskussion automatisch eine gute
ist es gibt konstruktive diskussion
sie können auch hart sein die können
kritisch sein das gehör richtige streit
sein
die kammer war das ziel probleme zu
identifizieren und auch um eine bessere
lösung zu bringen also was man sich
wenigstens vorwärts streitet es gibt
noch destruktive diskussionen wo es halt
einfach um die von empörung getrieben
sind
von aufregung wenn von spaltung wo man
überhaupt nicht vorwärtskommen wo man
auf der stelle bleibt und dann muss man
ja ihr problem mit der aktion dass sie
sich nach dem service also nach dem sinn
fragen na ja ich denke man kann ich fand
ich fand die aktion sage ich mal sehr
unglücklich weil es ich kann
sie total nachvollziehen was sie gerade
gesagt haben und dann nicht einfach das
dass sie das nicht vorausgesehen haben
dass das so aufgenommen werden könnte
aber was mich jetzt viel mehr nervt ist
dass wir mit den fans aber dass wir
jetzt immer noch drüber sprechen also
weil das das schlimme ist ja dass alles
dicht machen hat er deswegen oder nicht
deswegen so viel aufmerksamkeit bekommen
obwohl sie eine destruktive diskussion
angestoßen hat sondern eigentlich weil
weil medienschaffende aber natürlich
auch alle die medien konsumieren
empörung lieben oder zumindest mal
liegen ist zu hassen
und dann gibt es auf der anderen seite
aktionen wie zum beispiel hashtag
alarmstufe rot die jetzt seit vielen
monaten um aufmerksamkeit kämpfen für
die kultur und veranstaltungsbranche die
sich jetzt nicht in storms verwickeln
und dann nicht so viel aufmerksamkeit
bekommen und es sollte uns schon zu
denken geben unsere aufmerksamkeit
begrenzt ist ein kostbares gut kostbare
ressource wie wir wollen wir damit
haushalten sag ich mal
und wir belohnen momentan medial
diejenigen die am lautesten schreien und
schaukelt sich das dann so hoch dann
gibt es dann so formeln wie die er
leider auch für den journalismus gelten
empörung gleich klicks gleich einnahmen
und natürlich spaltet das am ende
irgendwie eine gesellschaft und das ist
ja ohnehin unschön das ist nur jetzt
gerade können wir das ja sowieso gar
nicht gebrauchen weil ich denke jede
spaltung verschlimmert diese pandemie
für alle und die frage nehmen wir ihnen
natürlich den wolfgang kubicki sehr
herzlich in der sendung zu größen
stellvertretender fdp vorsitzender und
stellvertretender
bundestags-vizepräsident jurist ist ja
auch noch sie haben die aktionen der
diese protest videos der schauspieler
unterstützer kubicki warum und muss man
um die frage von von ihm aufzunehmen
muss man eigentlich ja irgendwie gegen
korona politik sein und dann immer
zwangsläufig neben afd leuten oder co
pid gegnern laufen könnte man nicht
eigentlich auch bessere proteste finden
ja zunächst einmal kann ich nicht
beurteilen was eine konstruktive und
destruktive diskussion ist dass ich mir
gar nicht an diese unterscheidung kennt
die verfassung auch nicht und ich weiß
auch nicht was sinnvoll und ich sind
voll ist außer dass ich meine eigene
meinung habe wie anderen zweifel auch
was mich betrübt daran ich fand das sehr
pointiert die aktionen und ich fand die
reaktion darauf bis hin zur forderung
nach berufsverbot ziemlich unangemessen
weil offen sie die linien die das
fordern den wert von artikel 5 des
grundgesetzes nämlich dann mal ist die
kunstfreiheit gar nicht mehr kennen die
kunstfreiheit kann gar nicht
eingeschränkt werden und die
meinungsfreiheit ist nach ständiger
rechtsprechung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts eine der
fundamente unserer freiheitlichen
ordnung und deshalb denke ich wir müssen
aufpassen dass bei der korona debatte
nicht alle die die nicht den maßnahmen
die regierung sofort mit ganzem herzen
mittragen
zu wenige gemacht während die schwere
krankheitsverläufe todesfälle wollen ich
kam hinein frau erinnert er ist der
stolz vor einigen wochen bei ihnen saß
gemein sind mein bundesvize christian
linder und erklärt die fdp wolle im
parlamentarischen verfahren etwas
verzögert natürlich unsinn war um daran
anzuschließen wie er sein dann
verantwortlich für tote was ich ziemlich
unverschämt und ich kann sagen ich die
große koalition lange zeit brauchte mal
vernünftige vorlage zu nach nichts
verzögert worden ist wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir eine vernünftige
diskussion jetzt nicht einfach
emotionalisieren wie sieht das
vorhergesagte am team solidarität über
team der sicherheit gegen team öffnung
wir müssen die erkenntnisse die wir
haben zusammen führen denn eins ist
sicher die kanzlerin hat recht mit dem
virus verhandelt man nicht aber man
findet auch nicht mit der verfassung und
darauf lege ich ganz großen wert das
werden wir demnächst auch
gerichtsentscheidungen sehen
ich will kommen vielleicht noch dazu ich
komme aus einem bundesland was keiner
ausgangssperren hat was sehr niedrig
denn zahlen hat wir haben aus der
gastronomie oder viele andere dinge mehr
darüber muss dann jeweils diskutieren
denn eines muss klar sein auf dauer wird
die gesellschaft lassen was den look
down ähnlich aus seiten und das die
künstler sich jetzt gerade gewährte jan
josef liefers und andere verträge also
stellvertretend auch für andere kann ich
nachvollziehen
bei denen eben in der panne sehr viel
verloren geht sowohl einkommen wie auch
vor allen dingen ihrem publikum und das
ist glaube ich für einen künstler der
auftreten will
viel schlimmer als die erklärung er
würde auch ausgleichszahlung erhalten
dafür dass sie nicht tätig sein kann
wenn man diesen applaus von ganz rechts
bekommen herr kubicki hat man dann
zwangsläufig immer was falsch immer wie
ist das bei ihnen wenn die afg mit
anträgen von der fdp stimmen
das macht es ja nicht nur bei der fdp
die stimme damit anträge von den linken
und den grünen und auch der große
koalition also zu glauben ein argument
darf deshalb nicht gebraucht werden jan
josef liefers angesprochen weil man dann
auch applaus von der ard bekommt halte
ich für falsch das würde ich dadurch
falsch dass die afg oder querdenker
dessen zweifel auch aufgreifen man muss
wie gesagt nur aufpassen dass man sich
von ihnen persönlich nie vereinnahmen
lässt das kann ich ausschließen ich kann
ja jetzt persönlich jetzt kann ich bei
ihm ausschließen bei vielen dingen die
ich gesehen habe
das kann ich auch für mich ausschließen
aber wie gesagt wir werden nicht deshalb
besser indem man es dauernd distanzieren
denn dann überlassen wie er ist der afg
und den quer den können die diskussion
bei uns in deutschland wirklich zu
bestimmen wir fragen bevor wir bei dem
ersten bürgermeister hamburgs sind jan
josef liefers nochmal nach dieses
stichwort kann man gegen die krone
politik nicht auch demonstrieren ohne
neben der afg und corona leugnern zu
sein stichwort fünf vor zwölf die
demonstration beispielsweise der ärzte
oder der friseure oder es gab ja
verschiedene auch die wirte haben
demonstriert aber eben auch die künstler
bei alarmstufe rot
es gab auch einzelne den aktionen nicht
gut fand ich finde brenner zum beispiel
hatte das zweimal diesen anlauf gemacht
auf eine unheimlich zivilisiert und
schlau und smarte art es ist einfach
immer verhalte und das ist jetzt eben
auch was natürlich ist mir auch klar
dass die regierung unter beschuss stand
auch natürlich von der presse mit
verschiedenen entscheidung und zwar ist
mir alles klar
nur was natürlich auf die dauer auch
wahrgenommen wird von uns aber übrigens
nicht nur von uns aber darf jetzt nicht
nur denken dass uns nur rechte und und
verrückte zu geklatscht haben also meine
ich weiß nicht ob ich in den nächsten
zwei monaten dazu kommen dass alles zu
lesen
das ist ja mein punkt auch erwischt der
einfach nur alle sagen meine güte danke
endlich hat das auch mal jemand gesagt
das kann man nicht von der hand weisen
damals habe ich wieder den faden
verloren alarmstufe rot also hätte er
sie aber nie zusagen sind eben verhallt
und das ist das was natürlich auch dann
irgendwann auf gemacht dass du sagst ich
habe jetzt so versucht
ich habe es auch so versucht annahme so
versucht sind leute auf die straße
gegangen
herbert grönemeyer hat am schluss
gespielt und haben sagt duden loskommt
das machen wir lassen einmal raus weil
wie bei jeder der diese resistenz und
und okay wir sind bei herrn genscher dem
ersten bürgermeister der stadt hamburg
so viel habe ich schon gesagt muss man
corona leugner muss man irgendwie eben
von der afg sein oder von ganz rechts
sein um ihre politik zu kritisieren
nein es wird ja auch viel kritisiert
also ich habe mir jeden tag sehr viel
kritik an zu dem was wir entscheiden das
gegenteil ich auch nicht die
beschreibung der situation aber ich
verstehe jetzt wenn herr liefers
berichtet wie es ihm gegangen ist im
letzten jahr kann ich das gut
nachvollziehen es gibt ja viele die so
hin und hergerissen sind die auch
irgendwann möbel sind und die sagen
jetzt muss es auch echt mal zu ende sein
das verstehe ich als ich das video
gesehen habe war mir aber auch nicht
klar was ist jetzt ihre botschaft also
mein problem ist dass diese botschaft
die die sie vielleicht senden wollten
also mindestens missverständlich war und
das hat dann wiederum weil ja alle jetzt
so auf zinne sind marode
deswegen waren diese reaktion glaube ja
aber auch gerade die die genau wie herr
liefers hin und hergerissen sind sind
dann ja aber auch empört wenn sie das
missverstehen und ich denke immer doch
sehr stark an diejenigen die jetzt
sozusagen nicht mehr ganz so im nicht
gestanden haben zum schluss das ist die
situation auf den intensivstationen die
die wirklich schwer erkrankt sind und
deren angehörigen und die pflegekräfte
auch die müssen sich ja wenn sie das
video sehen fragen was ist die botschaft
und ich glaube das ist das vielleicht
etwas missglückte an dieser aktion dass
die botschaft bei aller kritik die
berechtigt ist nicht so richtig
verstanden werden konnte und so richtig
beifall haben sie glaube ich gekriegt
von personen bei denen sie eigentlich
gar nicht viel zu tun haben wollten dass
das kann man manchmal nicht vermeiden
wir kriegen ja in der politik auch
manchmal beifall von der falschen seite
aber ich glaube diese aufgeheizte
emotionale stimmung die wir ja alle
jetzt haben nach einem jahr corona
panini war
wie heißt das benzin haltige luft und
sie machen dann mal so ein schleicher
reichartz an und dann wie gesagt man
darf ja alles sagen ich meine herr
kubicki sagt jede meinung ist ist okay
man muss alles sagen dürfen kritisierte
herrn scholz für das was er stolz gesagt
hat das ist muss man sagen ja nun
sinnvoll und das ist unsere
demokratische öffentlichkeit die so
funktioniert und dann haben sie auch
gleich noch ein tolles verteidigt und ja
ein bisschen ist eigentlich herr chance
hat eine sehr plausible haltung zu
diesen punkten und ich teile sie
übrigens dass wir jetzt wirklich auch an
diejenigen denken müssen die am
härtesten wirklich auch von den
gesundheitlichen folgen dieser panini
wenn sie das jetzt zum zweiten mal sein
herz ja sie sind ein kluger mann
dann wissen sie auch dass wir zwei
probleme übereinander legen
es ist ja etwas ganz anderes zu beklagen
dass wir zu wenig pflegekräfte haben und
dass die jetzt übrigens auf den
intensivstationen in 13 monat durch
schrubben und das nicht die betten unser
problem sind sondern die pflegekräfte
das ist neu und es formulieren nicht so
wahnsinnig viele leute diese probleme
mit den pflegekräften hatten wir aber
schon vorher dass er schon vorher das
macht die lage aber ja nicht einfach
macht sich nicht einfach für die
betroffenen ist es dann so sie sind ein
jahr jetzt in diesem dauer stehr
leistungs situation und wir werden die
patienten auch noch jünger das ist auch
noch mal was ich habe auf der
intensivstation gehört dass die
pflegekräfte gesagt haben zu anfang
waren es sehr alte patienten die die wir
jetzt pflegen und die sterben sind
jünger als wir
man muss wirklich sehen die die folgen
auch seid ihr den wir diese britische
variante jetzt haben die noch infektiös
sind in dieser phase wirklich sehr sehr
hart und weil das alles so ein bisschen
abgenutzt war haben einige auch das
gefühl dass wir auf diesen diesen teil
der pandemie folgen nicht mehr so
empfindlich reagieren wie wir das noch
zu anfang getan haben und deswegen
glaube ich ist eine aufgeheizte eine
sehr polarisierte situation und sie sind
mit einer sagen wir mal mindestens
missverständlichen botschaft jetzt war
mitten rein gegangen und das hat diese
heftigen reaktion glaube ich habe eine
ganz unmissverständliche botschaft wäre
zum beispiel wenn man das schon so sieht
und ich sehe das auch und das war
überhaupt kein
seitenhieb auf irgendjemanden der in der
intensivstation
das leben von menschen kämpft gar nicht
aber wenn man das schon so sieht wie sie
sagen wäre es doch wäre es nicht cool
einfach zu sagen für die zeit ab anämie
verdoppeln wir einfach euer gehalten und
wir sehen überall seriöse leistung ich
kann dir sagen wir honorieren
wir haben einen drauf das ist toll was
ihr macht und das zeigen wir dadurch das
wäre doch eine schöne sache ist ein
anderes thema aber ich wäre sogar recht
wir haben ja deswegen auch über eine
sonderprämie gesprochen ich finde zum
beispiel wir brauchen
allgemeinverbindliche tarifverträge für
die pflege insgesamt ganz monaten schon
versprochen worden
sie sind leider jetzt im letzten moment
wieder gescheitert aber nicht an der
politik und es gibt viele ansätze die
wir auch verfolgen zum beispiel die
ausbildung zu verstärken aber was am
ende übrig bleibt ist eine akute
situation in der es nicht leicht ist
deswegen ist die intensivmediziner in
den letzten wochen auch so offensiv
geworden
es war ja nicht die politik der gesagt
das ist jetzt noch mal wirklich ganz
ganz streng sondern es war die
intensivmedizin der gesagt hat wir sind
jetzt wieder bei über 5.000
intensivpatienten und wir müssen davor
warnen dass das noch so weiter geht
noch mal die frage was wir jetzt auch
merken ist dass auf der einen seite
natürlich immer vor der bedrohung durch
das virus gesprochen wird und davor
gewarnt wird völlig zurecht und auf der
anderen seite reklamieren ja nicht nur
schauspieler sondern viele viele andere
menschen
das ist auch dramatische folgen jenseits
der physis und des körpers gibt für
diese gesellschaft kann man das so
gegeneinander stellen ist das überhaupt
klug zu glauben dass das gegeneinander
zu stellen ist ja der keine antwort ich
sehr gerne traurig bin nur ganz kurz
eine sache zu der zu den diskussionen
sagen weil ich finde wir sollten gerade
jetzt nicht so viel aufmerksamkeit auf
sehr extreme meinungen trägen weil
natürlich ist total banane dann
berufsverbot zu fordern und genauso wie
aber wenn ich mich jetzt zum beispiel
meine arbeit und ich rede nur über
wissenschaft ich ich ich kläre nur auf
ich sage sehr selten meine meine
persönliche meinung und videos also zum
beispiel bei meile von wenn dann ist die
wissenschaftlich begründet wenn ich da
mich jetzt auf solche
entsprechende nachrichten konzentrieren
würde wie berufsverbot oder schlimmer
wir hören ja auch von christian rost
oder karl lauterbach dass die
morddrohungen bekommen
dann würde ich ja dann würde ich ja gar
nichts gar nichts bekommen ja sondern
wir müssen uns klar machen das ist eine
sehr kleine minderheit und wir lassen es
zu wird dürfe nicht zulassen dass die
unsere diskussionen und gerade jetzt
weil es ja auch so viel glaube ich auch
diese pandemie die können wir nur
bewältigen wenn wir zusammenstehen und
auch wenn wir nicht irgendwie trotz der
ganzen müdigkeit unsere empathie
verlieren und dann kommen wir zu diesem
gegenüber stellen wo ich das ganz anders
wahrgenommen habe als sie herr liefers
also ich mich würde mal interessieren
vielleicht gibt es irgendwie eine gruppe
von medienforschern die sich das mal als
mal nachgehen wollen also wirklich das
verhältnis war bei ich hatte zum
beispiel den persönlichen dich ja nicht
subjektiven eindruck wieder da ich
dachte das wird ja viel zu viel geredet
über genau diese gegenüberstellung ja
wir wissen es ist gefährlich aber wissen
intensivstationen ja ja aber was ist mit
der wirtschaft was es mit dem diese
dichotomie diese falsche habe ich nicht
verstanden weil ich dachte ist doch das
beste für alle wenn wir möglichst wenig
ins tendenz also wirklich wenig
infektionsgeschehen haben und auch vor
allem langfristig zumal wir schon
suchten wussten ich meine viele haben
mich erst kennengelernt letztes jahr
durch mein video bewohner gibt gerade es
muss jetzt über ein jahr alt wo es ja
schon darum gehen wir müssen jetzt
irgendwie schauen wie kommen wir denn
jetzt wie kriegen wir denn es die
ausdauer jetzt über ein jahr und es ist
wir haben ja im sommer gesehen wie gut
macht war das gewesen wären ich meine
natürlich gibt es in gewissen sommerfeld
wir wissen dass der dazu beiträgt dass
das in diese schlimme aber wir hätten
problemlos im herbst das irgendwie genug
unter beweis und grüne bringen können
und ich glaube diese ganzen diskussion
dieses falsche gegenüberstellen das
gegeneinander ausspielen das hat sehr
sehr viel dazu beigetragen hat sehr viel
geschadet
und wie
natürlich um ein letztes mal auf die
aktion zurück zu kommen
jan josef doch bei der frage in welchem
zeitlichen zusammenhang des steht sie
haben das schon erwähnt dass sie hätten
sie wollten wann da eben dezember
eigentlich völlig satt sie haben alles
abgestellt sie konnten das nicht mehr
ertragen weil es einfach ein zuviel an
allem war ich kurz sagen es gibt noch
etwas anderes was mich so irritiert hat
ziemlich bald als es darum ging welches
bundesland macht jetzt die härteren
regeln und so weiter und das ist auch
eine sache die die die presse gemacht
hat und auch die die die die medien
wurde die pandemie bekämpfung ziemlich
früh anzufragen gekoppelt wie markus
söder läuft sich da ein kanzlerkandidat
warm und so das habe ich nicht
verstanden ich habe nicht verstanden wie
sowieso die die die berichterstattung
ständig diesen zusammenhang herstellt
zwischen machtinteressen und einer
pandemie bekämpfung dass zum beispiel
war schon so eine sache die viel so in
mich rein und wartete dann so rum
jetzt würde ich ja irgendwann im märz
und es hat natürlich damit zu tun dass
es genau zwei kandidaten für dieses amt
gab die sich der warmliefen es ist jetzt
in der bekämpfung der pandemie
tatsächlich auch schädlich gewesen dass
wir mitten in einem wald wir sind es ist
unstreitig für meine begriffe aber wo
war der punkt wo sie dachten da ist zu
wenig diskutiert worden oder da ist zu
wenig auf die menschen geschaut worden
wie sie da ist zu wenig darüber
nachgedacht worden wie sehr auch ganze
branchen darunter leiden die quasi also
klar entscheidung und durch die politik
arbeitslos erklärt worden und das hat
schon überall so konnte man immer mal
wieder arbeiten also ich möchte jetzt
noch mal ganz klar sagen dass die leute
die mit publikum zu tun haben pianisten
konzert musiker bands und alles was
hinten dran hängt einfach seit über
einem jahr komplett abgeschaltet wurden
es gab da zwischendurch mal ein kleines
loch wir haben also 23 konzerte noch
gespielt untergrund ablehnung super
funktioniert habe das ist dass tim
bendzko hat ein riesenprojekt in leipzig
gestartet wird das war eine
forschungsanlage die darüber gebaut
wurde das waren alles sehr sehr
ermutigende ergebnisse ja alles verpufft
und geht weg
und das hat natürlich auf die dauer ganz
schön frustriert und jetzt rede ich
manchmal nur von künstlern es gab auch
andere leute bei ich bin so ein typ
wenn ich irgendwo rum laufen gespräche
leute mal an und verwickelte mich im
gespräch und ich mag das auch in ordnung
sie stehen dann da am zaun dann redet
man ein bisschen und ich höre immer mehr
im verlaufe dieses jahres auch ein satz
den ich noch aus dem osten keller
versteckt vielleicht auch so müsste
meine biografie mit drin aber das darf
man jetzt ja nicht mehr sagen und ob das
nun stimmt oder ob das nicht stimmt klar
erstmal alles sagen aber man kriegt
schon auch also ungestraft nicht und
dann sehe ich so stumme schweigende
mehrheit minderheiten von dem man gar
nicht wahr ist die so in der
gesellschaft sich so bilden und so tann
so um mehr andern und und also dass das
finde ich schrecklich also wenn wir in
einer gesellschaft leben wo leute
wirklich echt dann irgendwann glauben
sie könnten das nicht mehr sagen weil
man immer gesagt von wissenschaftlern
also das kann man jetzt noch nicht sagen
also das finde ich ganz schrecklich
dagegen bin ich wirklich da würde ich
wirklich meinen letzten 1000 fenster
werfen und dagegen sind sie so
allergisch dass ich auch hinnehmen
durchaus mit eben nochmal diesem sound
auch von demokratie verächtern zu
arbeiten also zu sagen so ich habe dann
wieder und von demokratie wird jeder
zweifel irgendwie niedergetreten und er
wird immer in eine richtung geschrieben
und gesprochen und da wird nicht gehört
dass es eben auch ängste in so einer
gesellschaft gibt also das sind ja die
vorwürfe die sie sich anhören
naja man verlangt bei relativ
undifferenzierten maßnahmen die haben
mittlerweile gar nicht mehr
differenzieren
es ist schwer differenzierte kritik zu
verlangen und nicht zu erwarten also ist
das verstehe ich das nicht ich mache das
so pauschal gilt für alle
aber wenn du das kritisiert dann möchte
ich aber dass du ganz fein
differenzierten das heute trainieren
zusammen für mich und es geht ja nicht
darum den leuten irgendwie eins ins
gesicht zu hauen zu sagen oder so was es
geht ja darum was das anstößt es geht um
den moment was man sagt eine kunstaktion
die man sie nun auch immer findet soll
etwas anstoßen und wir machen ja kein
schlusspunkt alle suchen ja auch soweit
sobald sie das geld auf ihre art und
weise diesen dialog ist er jetzt auch
hier das ist als jetzt in ihrem video
gesagt haben passt ja jetzt nicht
unbedingt zu dem was sie jetzt alles
aber darum geht es doch bei so was also
aber dass ich würde doch gar nicht hier
sitzen wenn ich irgendwo gesagt hätte
und wisst ja leute ich will auch noch
einmal ganz klar hinweisen auf die
situation der künstler dann wären wir
hier nicht an dem punkt dieser knall so
vernehmlich der hat ja was disruptive es
von mir aus oder so man kann das aber
habe aber die entschuldigung haben sie
jetzt den künstler geholfen oder würden
sie jetzt sagen das war trotzdem gut wer
hauptsache aufmerksamkeit hätte also ich
kann ja nicht an die töpfe der also ich
weiß dass ganz viele von den hilfen noch
lange nicht angekommen sind also ich
weiß nicht ob es ihn könnte dann hilft
aber immer vielleicht vielleicht hat
diesen impuls gegeben
vielleicht hat es auch ein bisschen mehr
eingeschlagen als dieser der
zivilisierten sehr höflichen versuche
dies vorher gehabt ich meine ich kann ja
nichts dafür ich habe das ist ja nicht
nur das habe ich ja auch nicht gesagt
wir stürmen jetzt den reichstag oder so
die regierung ich finde es natürlich
quatsch ich finde es doch ganz wichtig
was das verbot schon öfter gesagt nur
weil man den applaus von der falschen
seite bekommt ist das argument an sich
nicht weil ich aber als person der
öffentlichkeit achte ich natürlich schon
auch drauf was hat was hat man jetzt
keine rolle in der pandemie sind ja als
als beliebter schauspieler haben sie ja
auch einen einfluss die wollten ja
versuchen den gut zu nutzen war ihnen
den mann nicht bewusst dass sie da auch
native bedienen die auch bei den quellen
kann ähnlich hallen und dass das
verstehe ich halt nicht oder haben sie
gesagt ich könnte eine relative der
querdenker jetzt nur richtig wenn jetzt
manche von denen sie den finde ich auch
gut dass sie sich dann direkt
distanziert habe aber das haben sie sich
ja trotzdem auf die auf die fahne
geschrieben die die nehmen das natürlich
mit es gibt es gibt natürlich menschen
die ganz bewusst nutzen und das auch
instrumentalisieren diese
entführungsfällen über die ich mich
vorhin schon aufgeregt habe um eben die
gesellschaft zu spalten und dann total
dankbar da jetzt einfach ihr video dann
meinetwegen zweckentfremden sich auf die
fahne schreiben und das ist jetzt etwas
nur ich kann total gut nachvollziehen
dass sie sagen ich kann ja jetzt nicht
jeden recherchieren ich kann es auch
total nach für wenn sie sagen ja ich
kenne auch die leute sind gute freunde
damit war es für mich abgehakt dass er
bestimmt eine gute aktion ich würde das
vielleicht also ich will
das tatsächlich grundsätzlich nicht
machen vielleicht bin ich ja zu sehr
wissenschaftlerin aber auch weil ich um
diese verantwortung bewusst bin was ist
wenn ich da was unterstütze was
vielleicht habe ich irgendwas nicht
durchdacht na ich stehe ja für was dann
auch ich beeinflusst die leute damit
auch und ich finde das natürlich sehr
schade dass das jetzt zu soviel wieder
jahr spaltung geführt hat sie bestimmt
auch aber ich finde auch schaute das ist
bestimmen reaktion geführt hat die nicht
intendiert war keine absicht ich das
find ich auch schade dass das mit der
spaltung angeht also wäre nun wirklich
hier spaltet ob wir die ursache sind
oder auch nur ein symptom das weiß ich
nicht da würde ich ihn letztlich fall
besteht vielleicht bin ich auch als
wissenschafts vermittlerin da habe ich
natürlich sehr viel damit zu tun weil
ich natürlich auch sehr viel androhung
anfeindung von der richtung bekomme aber
wenn sie mir jetzt ihr video vor gezeigt
hätten das hätte ich ihnen sehr voraus
also fand ich das eben sehr naheliegend
wirke gott dass das können sie nicht
machen